hello and welcome to another python
mathematics and stock indicators
tutorial
in this video we're going to be talking
about bollinger bands what are they how
to calculate them by hand
in the next video we'll be talking about
how to program them into python
and the video after that we'll be
graphing them using matplotlib and our
previous charting application that we
built
so bollinger bands uh what are they
they're created by john bollinger and
they're a registered trademark to him so
anytime you you know say bollinger bands
or
really right bollinger bands you've got
to like give him his little r
so there's that volatility measurements
uh basically what bollinger bands are
just it's a simple moving average on
either side you've got volatility
measurements
um so on the top side you've got a
volatility and on the bottom side you've
got a volatility
so because of their simplicity they can
really be used with
stocks forex options futures whatever
and actually
bollinger bands can be used with any
data line right so any data line that
you're going to put a simple moving
average on to like smooth it out
and you want to know like how volatile
is it you know kind of what the purpose
of standard deviation even
if you want to know that then you can
use bollinger bands so it doesn't even
have to be stock
anything it doesn't have to even have a
price but notably uh pretty much
everybody uses bollinger bands with
stocks
so the calculation of bollinger bands
pretty simple there's three bands
total to calculate uh here in our
equations we use
one variable of tf that's just time
frame
and the other one is x and x is just you
just make it up
so uh the middle band is just a
simple moving average of price with
whatever time frame you've chosen
the top band is that simple moving
average plus
the standard deviation of price for that
time period multiplied by x
again x is just whatever you choose
usually it's going to be a 2. we'll get
back to that
and the bottom band is again that simple
moving average
minus the standard deviation of price in
that time period again
multiply by x now typically time frame
is going to vary a lot more
generally it's somewhere around 20 x
i've never seen it be anything but two
but you could do you know a higher
number
especially for some stocks that are not
they're maybe volatile but they're
volatile in one direction
right so they're either going constantly
like going up or they're constantly
going down
uh you're going to find that your
bollinger bands are kind of
not working out for you so you might
want to use a higher number but
generally
20 and 2. so let's go ahead and show
some examples real quick of these
bollinger bands
let me bring up the application here
so we'll show we'll do ebay
so here's an example of ebay and their
bollinger bands
the bollinger bands are what we're
seeing right here right these three
lines
around price typically they're going to
be plotted right on there so you can
visually see the volatility there
so as you can see for the most part
price i mean ebay is a fairly volatile
one
especially coming up here but this year
you can even see how well it's
actually encapsulated the volatility
there um
so so you can see you know the
volatility like every
pretty much all the time you know prices
contained within these uh
you know the bollinger bands right so
let's look at uh another one real quick
um i'm trying to think of another good
one to do let's do uh we can do
starbucks
yeah so starbucks as you know or may not
know but starbucks has been kind of
rising in price
uh for a while now on a pretty
consistent scale
so um so you can see how much thinner
the bollinger bands are for uh
for starbucks right and so also it's
the price is pretty much every time it's
rising or falling
well at least here it was it was
contained pretty well
but especially like right here i mean
we've been outside that that range for a
while now
another good one to show that's even
even more pronounced would be like apple
because again we're on a 10 year time
scale here
so let's bring up apple and you can see
the pans are so close
uh that it pretty much just looks like a
20 simple movie
average that's pretty much what it is
but if we did zoom in enough you would
see
that it's actually three bars or three
lines rather
so yeah anyway so those are bollinger
bands and again
like apple if you wanted to fix that you
would change your multiplier most likely
and that would do it for you
so anyways uh that's bollinger bands
that's how to calculate them by hand
and in the next video what we're going
to be doing is actually programming it
into python and then we'll actually plot
it up so you guys can plot up what we
were just looking at
so as always thanks for watching thanks
for the support and subscriptions and
until next time